-Well, for those of you keeping
track at home,
the president's friends are
Vladimir Putin and Kim Jong-Un,
and his enemies are Playboy
bunnies and Joe Biden.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Did you hear about this?
First Joe Biden said that he
would have beaten up Trump
in high school.
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump tweeted that he'd
beat Biden in a fight
and Biden would go down
fast and hard.
[ Laughter ]
And women everywhere said
thank God we didn't elect
an emotional woman
to lead our country.
[ Laughter ]
Now we have this to deal with.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Even though they're both
in their 70s,
Biden and Trump
are talking about fighting.
[ Laughter ]
Experts say the match
would go nine rounds
with 10 bathroom breaks.
-Ho!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's crazy.
Biden and Trump are threatening
to beat each other up.
It got even weirder
when Bernie Sanders
ripped off his shirt and yelled,
"Tag me in, let's do this thing!
Come at me, bro!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come at me, bro.
Straight after Biden brought up
the idea of fighting Trump,
the president sent this tweet,
and this is real.
He said, "Crazy Joe Biden is
trying to act like a tough guy.
He doesn't know me,
but he would go down fast
and hard, crying all the way."
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Then Biden actually replied.
He said, "White House,
bike racks, 3:00, be there!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Then Trump said, "Uh, I can't.
I told my dad
I'd wash the car at 3:00."
Then Biden said, "No way, you
can't back out! No backsies!"
And then Trump said,
"No backsies, infinity!"
[ Laughter ]
Hopefully they can work it out.
Some tech news.
I saw that
since Facebook's data breach,
a lot of users
have deleted their accounts.
Which is tough, because now they
come over to your house
to show you pictures of
their kids in person.
And you're like, "Yeah, that's
great. Like, like, like."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Last night Mark Zuckerberg said
he's focused on
rebuilding trust.
Facebook users said that
lying is unacceptable.
Then went back to RSVP'ing "yes"
to events they'll never go to.
It's like, uh, maybe?
Listen to this.
Marvel is calling the upcoming
film, "Avengers: Infinity War"
the most ambitious
crossover ever.
Though, I'm pretty sure the most
ambitious crossover ever
is actually President Trump's
hair.
I mean, it starts here,
and it's like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I told you, I think he uses
a Dyson Airblade.
-Does he really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I saw that Toys "R" Us
is having a giant
"going out of business" sale.
[ Audience aws ]
So you can either go to the
store today and pay half price
or pay nothing at the Dumpster
behind the store tomorrow.
It's up to you.
You make your plans.
I don't make plans.
I heard about a man in Arizona
who called the police,
asking if the dinosaur
decorations in his local park
were real dinosaurs.
The cops said no,
but the mushrooms you ate
were definitely real, so...
[ Laughter ]
Sit down, maybe.
Finally, you guys,
Easter is coming up,
and a lot of people are getting
ready for the big holiday.
So we went down to the NBC Plaza
to ask people
about their Easter plans.
The only catch is,
they all had to answer
with a mouthful of Peeps.
I'll show you what I mean
in another installment of
"Where My Peeps At?"
Here we go.
♪♪ -Where my Peeps at, ooh ♪♪
-What are your plans for Easter?
-I'm going to my mother's.
My mother's house.
-[ Mumbling ]
-What was that last part?
-Do you really want to know?
I have to get a colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
-Eat Peeps.
Eat Peeps.
-We've got a great show tonight!
Give it up for the Roots,
everybody!